what do you think of the
the uh
the finale there with oliveira and uh
emporia
so you know uh
that's that's a great fight um
it just
it looked to me like oliveira
had more weapons in his arsenal and
that's what it came down to
you know um
like
here was a telling sign for me too
during a fight um when oliveira got that
first takedown
uh here's the difference okay
oliver gets dropped what does dp do
tries to knock him out no he lets him up
didn't he
let me think i i swear he let him up
yeah maybe he let him up huh
and
and it's just like
he is a lot better at the boxing but
this is in poija's mind he's thinking
i'm gonna knock this guy out with boxing
oh
and yeah i think that's his that's his
natural first thought it's his natural
first starters i'm gonna let him up and
box with him and knock him out some more
i'm gonna drop them again now
this is what coach bryce says and coach
bryce ain't [ __ ] on poy poya come over
here and beat my ass right now and
actually i want to train with him you
know i'm not i'm not saying but looking
back at a fight you can look back at all
my licenses and say hey you should have
coulda and i'll say yeah you're right
right yeah it's easy for us to sit here
and say anything so [ __ ] easy but if
say we re redo it and i'm wanting dp my
dude to win right and i'm dp's coach and
say if i say it he does it right i say
when you drop him get his guard
grind out that first round maybe you're
not gonna finish him probably unless you
hurt him real bad because charles got
that guard but do not
ever be scared to engage on the ground
with an opponent yeah that fear will
manifest itself i promise you and it's
not saying he's not afraid of charles
oliveira's ground game that's not what
i'm saying but right it's more like too
much respect
it's like bro you're dustin poije and
he's [ __ ] rocked you get on him and
you just keep [ __ ] just just whale
down punches and if i was his coach i
would tell him i don't give a [ __ ] how
good his guard is yeah you get in there
and you [ __ ] him up his guard ain't
gonna be that good right you know what
i'm saying and so yeah i could see it
being a level of like respect thing it
was it was a level of respect
yeah he just has this like uh
there's like he has this
this mutual kind of thing yeah and like
i said he wanted to knock him out with
the boxing yeah but if i was coaching
i'd be dustin going there getting his
guard uh you know keep him down and and
just win the rest of that round conserve
a little bit of your energy right um
then the second round i believe that
oliveira gets dp down and this is what
yeah that's when oliveira got him down
and was throwing those elbows they
weren't landing like it didn't look
super flush but some i'm sure they were
they were uh
oh they hurt yeah bro when they hit you
in the teeth you could feel because they
were laying right here and here and
uh you know those elbows hurt you know
um
but he had a body triangle walked around
his body and you can do that every now
and then you know because to kind of
recover or anything but i think he held
that body trying he's actually holding
himself in that position oh dustin was
the whole time he's damn right so it's
having a gas mile well dustin was kind
of holding trying to keep his body close
to him i think so he didn't have that
distance to to attack
because he didn't want his back get
taken and so and so um i would tell him
i'd say dustin open that bodytron you
cannot how can you stand up on your feet
if they're locked around your opponent i
say dustin you've got to knock this guy
out or you got to at least bust him up
you got to open your legs up and you got
to fight to get up now the problem
because if he opens his legs up then
what's possible putting his feet on the
ground planting them and getting up
getting back up now the risk there is
that oliveira circles to his back or
grabs a headlock but here's the thing
would you rather
the dude choke you out with the rear
naked choke or get you in a guillotine
on the way up
or would you rather sit and lose that
that that round by round by round with
that body triangle and uh you know i've
done a lot of bad things in fight but i
think when he looks back at it he'll say
you know what
i'm not going to do that body triangle
no more i'm going to get back to my feet
if my opponent gets me down because he
was kind of keeping himself there in
that position but it all came
all those all those things you saw was
the manifestation of the over respect
that he gave to all of vera yeah and i
say oh it's one thing to say okay oliver
is good on the ground and i don't want
to go to the ground with him it's
another to say he's so good on the
ground i'm not going to open up my guard
i'm going to hold him on top of me no
you can't be giving him that much
respect [ __ ] that
yeah i think dustin just loves fighting
so like the actually yeah he likes it
here's the thing you get a mat you get a
match up like um so if i was good at it
i would do it if i'm you know if i'm
good with a dagger i ain't gonna tickle
somebody that's what i know what i'm
saying so it's like just because it's
like it's not the same thing well you
know there's there's matchups like for
poi a that i just think he'll win every
every one like the perfect match-up for
him uh is conor mcgregor yeah uh a guy
who who power punches um
doesn't do as good in the later rounds
he does better in the first rounds
whereas dp does better in the later
rounds
so you get a dp in a conor mcgregor
matchup there's not a time in the fight
where dustin has to worry about getting
taken down getting choked
he's in his element and you're good
you're going to see him fully unleashed
but you put him up against the charles
rivera
oliveira and you're going to see in some
positions more timidity because of that
respect for the ground game and i don't
and this is my honest assessment of
dustin's ground game i don't think the
disparity's as big as it is in his head
right i think he was a little bit too
worried about oliveira's ground game
like i said when he dropped him i'm
pouncing
yeah i don't know i i didn't i didn't
talk to him enough about the actual
fighting and stuff before about what his
mindset was he's good on the ground man
i think he was just expecting the third
round it would get back up to
the feet the feet yeah and then that's
where it would kind of stay and so we'd
have a you know
and then it just it just and i think
also i think dustin was most bummed well
this this i got to say this my last loss
guy took me down and i got choked out
trying to get up you know so i've been
on the other end of it so it's just it
you know it's easy to sit here and say
oh you could have shoulda woulda but my
last fight bro i wish that i would have
got up safer i don't
if anything maybe i should have stayed
on the ground the rest of the fight
because i could have won a decision
possibly but
uh i learned a valuable lesson man and
um
every fight there's something to learn
yeah i mean look i obviously have you
know like i get scared of things yeah
i'm scared of something there's so i
know nothing but it's like it's
definitely just it's interesting to sit
back and talk about it and it's what we
do as humans we see what happened and we
look at it and
and it's like i just know also dustin
was bombed probably he wanted to fight
more that's the thing too and i think
it's the same with guys like you it's
like you just want to fight more like we
got five let's at least do four you know
i'm saying like even if you already won
let's do another you know like um
let's just keep it going uh
man the energy in there was so wild man
um
if you engage you was back's gate she's
just backstage literally it's like who
can i fight who can i fight who cannot
fight he's ready to go oh bro he's ready
to go
let me tell you why i think that um
gaichi is a great matchup for all of
arabic yeah what do you think what do
you think would happen to oliveira get
you because i feel like that's probably
what's going to be next i don't think
you're going to see a
poirier oliveira rematch because i think
it makes sense well he could go make
money fighting mcgregor that's what i
think you know he might just get that
that money fight or uh nate diaz fight
they would pay him so much money for
that nate diaz fight
he's in a position bro he don't even
have to worry about fighting for the
belt he's a [ __ ] bajillionaire or
whatever he is you know what i'm saying
like yeah he's made him some money in it
so he's it's not going to be typical
with him he's going to do something
crazy i bet you you know so what does
the belt mean to people because dustin
was an interim champion so that is a
that's a champion
you know it's um especially with the way
the belt is kind of used as like a
it's a bait they use it sometimes it's
who's definitely obviously it's always
who's great
but sometimes it's used by the
administration over there it seems like
it is like a well you know everybody's
path is different and i don't think that
these people who have the belts are
[ __ ] built different than anybody you
know they had good circumstances and
yeah and and a lot of them are great and
everything and and our elite and stuff
but i put it this way man
if i'm in a [ __ ] street fight
and i'm fighting for my life and and
there's one person i have my back and
and they said it's dustin poirier yeah
i'm thinking [ __ ] yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] what belt he's got this or that
does some poi can fight anybody yeah i
don't care if he's wearing it i don't
give a [ __ ] who it is i don't care if
he's wearing a belt from banana republic
that's right i want dp having my back
you know what i'm saying
and uh you know here's another thing man
with that that championship stuff man
it's like
i hate to see these people get the belt
and then they act like they're gods or
something you know what i mean like it's
um
okay mcgregor double champ right yeah
okay dp ain't a [ __ ] double champ
okay who wins when they fight right you
know
you know who wins right so it's
interesting it's interesting it ain't
all about that right and people's paths
are different
he has a lot of fights he had some rough
nights and you know it
he's a championship fighter i don't give
a [ __ ] if he has a belt or not like i
said i'm comfortable with him having my
back in any street fight amen man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you